[音楽]
今日は体と心についての
この わかりやすく言えば
どう管理すればいいということだと思います
で なぜそういうテーマになるかというと
この世の中でよくあることなんですけど
特に仏教についてはものすごいこの誤解しかないというとこがあるんですよ
誰でもそういう風になってしまうんですね
いつでも偏見でしか見てくれない
とにかくどうか頑張って仏教だけは馬鹿にしてやるぞと
そういう努力で もうあらゆる人々は研究したりする
もうちょっと親切に ちょっとなんて言いますか
批判いうか この固定概念ないような感じで見た方がいいのに
ほとんどやってくれないという特色が
もう昔からもう仏教に付いている悪い縁なんですよ
それでちょっと舐めただけで
自分こそ全部知ってるんだと
あなた方は何知ってるんですか？と言って
このまた仏教の人々を攻撃しようとするという
これは何なのかと だから本当に真面目に仏教は勉強している人々っていうのは
別に人に言いふらすこともしないし
自分で落ち着いて勉強して修行して
これで穏やかな生き方はしていますけどね
それで そういうふうに実践している人々のことはもうないがしろにして
ただ研究だけして 全くもう信頼もしない
間違っていると堂々と思っていて
研究したりして もうとことん仏教という教えにもう潰してやると迷惑をかけてやるぞということでは頑張ってますね
でも仏教もあまりも頑固で
もうなかなかそう簡単には死なないんですよ
ですから これからも仏教に対するもう巨大強烈な攻撃っていうのはね
あるとは思いますけどね
日本では仏教っていうのを知ったのは
これ白人が仏教はということを研究しているんだということで
随分もう 100年経ったから目が開けたところで
なるほど白人もやってるんだと
それでその人々の言葉を通して
ブッダという人がいたっけというふうなことで
日本でも研究を始めて
どうせ財産お金があるんですから
今は研究の場合は日本の方が優勢になってますけどね
西洋の方はお金も出す必要ないということで
研究施設などなどはほとんど衰退して衰えてはいますけどね
で 西洋で仏教を研究した人々っていうのは
別に仏教ありがたいっていう気持ちでやったわけではなくて
この野蛮人の教えをなんとか潰さなくちゃいけないとね
なかなか潰せないんだと
何かあるんじゃないかな
ですから研究しようということで
教会はお金を出してくれたんですよ
ですから この西洋仏教研究っていうのは
もう半分以上
教会のお金でやったもんで
大学では公のお金を出している場合でも
研究する人々は結局は宗教関係の方々で
仏教教授とかなんとか言っても
結局キリスト教の聖職者なんですよ
学問研究になってくると
それなりにしっかりした科学的な研究はちゃんとやっていることは確かでしょうし
別に何だかんでももう偏見でやるということはそれほどはないんですけど
それでも仏教という教えに対してはすごい不親切であることだけは不親切なんですね
なぜかというと この西洋で決まった決まりというのは
このキリスト教を研究する同じ基準で
同じ尺度でやらなくちゃいかんとということはいいんだけど
キリスト教の研究の場合は
キリスト教に対しては大変親切で
で ありのまま研究はするんですけど
気に入らんものは気に入らんと言うし
気に入るものは気に入るというし
で これはちゃんとやってますけどね
仏教に対してはそこら辺ではちょっとあの
結構不親切になってしまうんですね
ですから このラモットさんという亡くなったんですけど
フランス人のかなり巨大な大物の仏教学者で
カトリック教の神父さんでもあって
研究はすごいものなんですけど
フランス語でしか書かれてないんですけど
で それで ドイツ人のコンゼという
これまたすごいですよ
びっくりするほど能力なんですね
本なんか読んでみたら
びっくりすると思いますよ
この鋭い能力と言語学能力と分析能力っていうのはもう並みじゃないんですね
で やっぱりどこかでもうねじ曲がっちゃうんですよ
教えを だからどうにもならんですよ
学者としてもう申し分のない
もう抜群ですよ これほど人間に能力があるかって疑われるほど
もう西洋哲学であろうが
東洋のものであろうが
言語学絡みでも 西洋東洋全部ほとんど知っていて
だから我々よりはもう資格ものすごい取ってるんですよ
そういうことですから
何も言えないしね こちらもそういうテキストなんか読んで勉強するしかもうどうにもならんし
で そこでちょっとねじ曲がると
それから現代時代になってきて
いくらかこのやり方はまたまずいと
宗教研究っていうのは
こうやってこの外からいちいち悪口を言うんじゃなくて
分析っていうのはその中からするものであると
批判でも その中身から中からするものだよということで始めて
そういう人々はいくらか現代人だから
ベースに何か宗教っていうことはないんですよ
それで この現代時代で書かれた論文などは
前のものより激しく批判的なんです
初期時代の研究論文よりは
この 3代目の研究論文というか
3代目  4代目にあたるものは激しい批判的なんですけど
いいんじゃないかと思うけど
そういう そういえばそういうところもあるんじゃないかなとかね
思われる批判なんですね
批判は激しいんだけど
わざとねじ曲げるということではなくて
この中身を見て中身から言っているものだから
そういう批判だったらいいんじゃないかなというふうに思われることもあるんですよ
それから そういう教授たちが
いくらか仏教徒もいるし
研究途中で気に入っちゃって
自分たちもいい加減で
私も仏教徒やと というふうなことも言いふらしたりするし
で だから仏教徒やという一言葉で
仏教とかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの敵扱いはしないという意味だけはあるんですね
敵扱いしないんだけど
気に入らんことは気に入らんと言うんだと
そういう批判っていうのは
客観的で決して悪いものではありません
ですから 仏教を批判して悪いというわけじゃないんですね
このやり方なんですね
問題は だからどうしても気に入らん
もう嫌だったら放っておけばいいんですよ
で ですから 批判する場合はいくらかのやり方っていうのもあるんですね
その中でこの出てきた一つ
特によく日本でも見えることで
この仏教のお釈迦様やら誰でもいいんですけど
教えた何か一部だけ 一行二行三行だけね
で取ってみて それがもうそれなりにもう何か比較して比べて
翻訳として読んでみて
それこそ仏教やと
それで他のところを研究している人に対してすごく批判的になるんですね
で この間も私にもあなたはスッタニパータの792番目でしたっけ？これどう思って間違ってると思いましたとかね
思いますと思っているんでしょうか？とか
こちらももう怒りますからね
あんたそれしか知らないかと聞きたくはなるんでしょうし
それでその偈を読んでみてね
あなた方わかってるんですか？意味はと
と逆に聞きたくなるんですよ
これ 誰かがもうちらちらといい加減で
日本訳したものを読んだでしょうし
その意味じゃないんですけど
書いてるのは スッタニパータの特にaṭṭhakavagga pārāyanavaggaところの偈一つの分析さえも
当時の阿羅漢たちさえもすごくもう遠慮する
びっくりする もうできるだけ
もうあまりにも意味が深くて
たった一言葉わかりやすく分析しようと思ったら
もう何冊の本もなるほどもうすごいもんなんですね
だから大変ありがたいことに
原文では読めないという
随分恵まれている状況だから
いい加減なことを言うんですよ
だから私たちは足かせ手かせでもう原文で読みますから
いきなりびっくりして
もうどうもごめん
ごめん 遠慮しますということになってしまうんですよ
だから今日もちょっと読んでみたんですけど
あのその そういう話をした人に対して
私は一言葉に このサーリプッタ尊者にお釈迦様を教えたところなんですけどね
で ただ この人を呼ぶ時
お釈迦様は一つの言葉を使ってますよ
こういう人々の場合はとか
その人に形容詞に使っている言葉で私は引っかかったんです
これやりきれるもんじゃないんだと
だから意味わかってるんだから
あまりにももう広大な意味で
だからもう いろいろね
自分こそ知っている
他人が知らないという
この態度っていうのはよくある
で それでかえってブッダの教えに対してはかなり迷惑なんですね
だからお釈迦様というのは
そう単純簡単に把握できる
我々の知識で 把握できる
そこら辺のある事実とは違うんですよ
なんでそう思うんですかと
もうちょっと もうもうちょっと頭のいい人だとかね
思ったら何が悪いんですかね
もう何のことないくだらんことをやっている人々は
神様や天才やと拝んでもいる世界で
なんでブッダだけそうやって軽視されて
もう馬鹿にされて扱わなくちゃあかんかと
だからみんなを片っ端から批判するんだったら
それはそれでいいんですよ
誰でも批判してやるぞと言うんだったらね
そうでもなく ブッダだけ馬鹿にしてやるぞという態度は私は気に入らんですよ
だからこそなんですよ
仏教の世界で このあらゆる宗派なんか出てきたって
もうこれ全部 私はこの先生を侮辱することやと思いますよ
何か一言葉取って それで好き勝手に分析やら自分の我が意見というかね
主見 主観ばっかり語って語って宗派を作ったら
もうとっくにブッダから脱出してるんですよ
それで別な思考体系になる
別な思考体系になったら
別な思考体系で生き延びればいいのに生き延びないんですよ
それでまたブッダにコンタクトして
これこそ仏教だと言って
自分の命をなんとかして保ってもらうんですよ
だからブッダを批判しているのに
この何て言いますか もう死にかけてるんだからね
ずっとこの英語でハートランマシンという機械ありますね
人工呼吸器
だからブッダの人工呼吸器もつけてあげなくちゃいけない
だから私の話なんか聞いちゃうと
あのスイッチが切れちゃうんですよ
これ で もう私が間違っていると
なんで永久的にこの仏教を壊す人々にね
ずっと人工呼吸器をね
つけてあげなくちゃいかないんですかと
なんで自分の足で自分立ってね
自分の思考をね 堂々と語ればいいでしょうに
世の中は自由だから 人は何言おうが
これは自由な世界でしょうに
批判しようが それまた自由でしょうに
批判しながら助けてくれと
あんたは間違ってるんだけど
私を守ってくれと こんなのはちょっとね
インテリ的なやり方ではないんですよ
そういうふうなことが出てきて
これは今日はもうあまり関係ないことは言いましたけど
一つ昔からあるポイントで
仏教はもう暗い 生きてる人間の役に立つことは何一つも言ってない
反社会的やと で そういう立場あるんですよ
インターネットにも あの
全くこの反仏教的で
もう全くもう仏教を壊そうという気持ちで
一人がもう出てきて いろいろ質問出してあったんですけどね
で ホームページの我々のこの品格のいい態度壊れるんだから
もうやめましたけど
答えるのはね で そちらはもう頑固たる固定概念があって
仏教っていうのは このもう社会の教えじゃなくてホームレスの教えやと
俺たちには関係ないんだと
勝手にやれと 勝手にやって成功したらもう褒めてあげるぞと
で そういう態度がもう頑固と取っていて
もうガチャガチャいろんなことを言いたくなる
だから相手にもならん
だから何々経典 あんたどう思いますけど
私に逆にあなたわかってるんでしょうかと
あなたに関係ないでしょうに
こちらの教えだから どうやってこの翻訳だけで読んだ人がすべて知っていて
その本家の人々が知らないってことを言えるんですかね
よくも言うこと これは私が
あんた方は日本語はたまに冗談で言いますけど
それは冗談でからかっていうことで
別に だからあまりにもおかしいんだから冗談として言うんですよ
この早川さんによくあんた日本語わからないバカだからとか何とかとかね
でもそれ自体が冗談で明確でしょうね
これ 日本人に向かってあんた方は日本語わからないと
俺がわかってるよと言ったっても
これ成り立たん話でしょうに
ですから 仏教を信仰して
仏教を理解して 仏教の中で生きている人にとっても
ちょっとなんか一行わかってないでしょというのはね
これは気をつけて言った方がいいんですよ
だから仏教はもう人を侮辱しないんだからって
それをいいことにして
そういうことっていうのは困るんですよ
そういうことで 仏教っていうのは暗い話だと
西洋でもね  １８００年代で始めた時の研究とかね
ブッダは人間にとっては役に立つことは言ってないんだと
堂々と言う 例としてどこかから経典一つ取ったら
お釈迦様は出家主義を語っている
明らかに出家主義を語ってますよ
故に仏教は出家主義やと言えるかと
それを言うためにはかなり研究しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからみんな 特にスッタニパータテキストっていうのは
仏教の中でも最高なもの
最高っていうのは一番古いもので
言葉も古いし 意味もわからないところもたくさんあるし
普通に経典にあるパーリ語とパーリ語さえも違うんですよ
パーリ語は古典語ですけど
古典語の中にも古典語で
それで現代インドのサンスクリット語
古いヴェーダ語から見ても
ちょっとわからないところっていうのはもうあるんですよ
だから このそれは仏教を始めたその瞬間というかね
お釈迦様は一人しかいなかったとかね
あるいは弟子一人二人しかいなかった
あの巨大なインドの中で
そこでこの山の中から
森の中から 誰かものすごい優れた哲学者か宗教家や仙人みたいな人が来て
もうこのギリギリの真理を
ギリギリのところは 一行二行
三行四行で語っちゃうんですよ
だからそちらにはもう社会なんかはもうあっちいけ
関係ないんですよ ブッダという一人の人が何か教えを求めて
これも社会と関係ないでしょうに
だから その場合はもう全くこの真理そのものを語っているという
でもそれはこのもう強烈な仙人にしか通用しない
40年 60年間 もう社会から離れて
もう何一つも社会活動をしないで
もう徹底的にもう真理を探すために頑張った人には通じるんですけど
一般の人に通じるものじゃないんですよ
ですから 宗教の専門家にも通じるものじゃない
特定の だからその人間のレベルですね
そういうレベルで語ったら
一行二行出しちゃって
例えばあの犀の角ってKhaggavisāṇasuttaṃってありますね
社会っていうのはもう汚い
汚れてる 出ていけと そこはありますよ
じゃあ だからあなた方何やってるんです？世界の仏教徒は何やってるんですか？あなた方は一人も仏教者ではないやと
これ一行出して言えるんでしょうかと
では 他の教えはどうしますか？と
誰かさんがたまたま一行読んだんだからといって
膨大な仏典をあれ捨て
捨てなさいと なんでや
私は読んでないんだからと
そんな理屈成り立ちますかね
私は読んだのはこの一行ですよと
だからそれはもう それは正しくて
あんた方それは間違ってるんだよと
ある日本の新興宗教の人も
もうそうやって私に抗議かけてきたんですよ
駅の前で なんか変なことを言ってね
ブッダが生まれ変わっているんだぞとかね
そうだったら付き合ってくださいと
それはだからあなた方はもういかがでしょうかね
ブッダに会ってみたら関係ないやと
忙しいんだと と言ったんですね
そしたらまたいちいちもう言うんですね
そしたらもうあんた何か証拠でもありますかと
そしたら いい加減なことを言ったらバレますからね
ちょっと言いませんですけど
で 私は頭が悪いんだから
だいたい明確に物事を覚えておくんですよ
ですから 言えることは言いますけど
言ってはいけないしね
それで私はそれでどうしようもないんだから
もういろんな経典から引用してあげたんです
そういう経典にこうあります
こういう経典こうありますけどね
あんた言ってることというのはもういい加減ではないかと
その経典全部間違ってます
それで終わり その人のは
だったらどうやってあなたが言うことが正しくて
私が引用すること間違ってるんでしょうかと
ちゃんとテキストから引用してるんですけど
それは間違ってると 私が言うことは正しいと
あ そうですか と じゃあ勝手にしなさいと
言って帰りましたけどね
思い出す時でもすごく気持ち悪いんですよ
だからちょっとダイエットしたければ
そういう人々の顔を思い出せば
もうダイエットもできます
それぐらい気持ち悪いんです
そういうことで このブッダがこの人間
ただこの出家主義を語った
世界は悲観的で見た 何一つも評価してない
そんなことを言うと それも偏見もいいところで
ブッダが完全に真理を語ってるんですよ
そこで喋る場合は いろいろ尺度を作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから言葉で完全に語れないという言葉の問題があるんですよ
言葉自体が偏見なんです
言葉自体が主観なんですよ
だから ある面で言えば
言葉でモノは通じないんですが
そういうコミュニケーションできない手段を使ってコミュニケーションしなくちゃいけないんですよ
何か物を切ろうと思って選ばなくちゃいけない
刃物が切るためにふさわしくないものを選んでくださいと
切れないものを選んで切ってくださいというのは勝負なんですよ
ですから 通じない言葉を使って
我々人間が互いに話し合わなくちゃいかないんですよ
その問題はお釈迦様は
それなりには解決していたんですよ
それだけでもお釈迦様はすごいと私は思ってますよ
不完全な言葉なのに 誤解にならないようによく話しましたからね
そこで日本でよくある言葉がありまして
対機説法というね で これまた誤解していて
この対機という言葉と出てきたのは
やっぱりこの単語の選び方というのは
それぞれ条件によって成り立つものなんですよ
ですから それは
対機説法だと言って だから正しくないと言えるんでしょうかね
そこら辺もおかしいしね
だから私が持ってる単語を借りて話す
私が持っていない単語で話してくれてもわからないんですよ
皆様に喋るんだから日本語を使っているんですが
ドイツ語で喋っても喋れませんだけど
喋ったってもわかりますかね
ですから 私は日本語とこの日常生活のことやら
テレビから拾ういろんな情報やら
そういうものを使って喋ってますよ
だから仏教を壊してるわけじゃないんですよ
これを皆様が持っている道具
基準 尺度 そういうものを使ってコミュニケーションをとっているだけのことなんです
だから待機説法っていうのはそういうものなんですね
だから仏教を語る人にとっては
必ずしもあって なくてはならない一つの能力のその一つなんですよ
だから この経典丸暗記してそのまま吐くんじゃなくて
暗記したものをペラペラと喋るのは
これは楽なんですけど
相手の持っている概念
単語 表現 それに入れてあげられる能力
だからこの この間 このヴィパッサナー中心にジャータカ物語とか書いてるところで出たか覚えてないんですけど
このもう特別な能力とともに阿羅漢になりましたと
一行はすごい苦労して訳しましたですけど
それはこのpaṭisambhidāというパーリ語の言葉があるんですよ
これはもう日本訳はない
なんか変な訳はありますけど
訳した人はわかってないと思いますけどね
で paṭisambhidāというものは４つありまして
時々この修行する人々にはすぐ身につくんですよ
この４つの能力が このpaṭisambhidāの能力って何なのかというと
この人に語れる能力なんですよ
真理は語れないんですよ
語れない真理を真理知らない人々に紹介する
案内する その特別な能力は何のことなく身についてしまう
paṭisambhidāっていうのは
このインスピレーションみたいな英訳ですればね
インスピレーションというものはいっぱいあると
これ４種類ですよ attha-paṭisambhidā
dhamma-paṭisambhidā
nirutti-paṭisambhidāというね
attha dhamma nirutti paṭibhāna
4つですけど そこら辺に見たってもかなりの世界ですよ
一行で訳しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで特別能力ということを訳したんだけど
その中またすごい世界ありますよ
attha-paṭisambhidāって何ですかと
dhammaって何ですかと
これすごい また別ですごい世界ですよ
ですから それ全部をまとめてみたっても
この表現能力なんですね
語れる能力 瞬時に問題を見つけて
相手が持っている問題を見つけて
ではこういうふうに答えるべきですよと
で これはこの修行するとヴィパッサナー瞑想をちゃんとやると
なんとなく能力ついてくれる人もいるし
全くついてこない人もいますけどね
で 能力ついてない人々はただ黙っている
能力ついた人は黙っていたら失礼だからということで
それなりに人々に説法を語る
仏法を語る それだけのことですけど
で  そういうわけであのお釈迦様がいろんな尺度から話してます
で 例えば40年間一生 出家生活した人がいるとしますね
ブッダの物語の中でこういう物語
ナーラカという物語がありますよ
このナーラカっていうのは
お釈迦様が生まれた時
お釈迦様のこの占ってあげた
このバラモン人の８人がいて
その中の一人の命なんですよ
で その一人のバラモン人が
自分が年だからもう死んじゃいますよと
このシダッタ王子がもう真理を発見するんだと
でもその時は自分がもう死んでいるんだと
あ ナーラカじゃない アシタ仙人のですよ
間違えました で このアシタ仙人がそれを見て自分が死んでしまっちゃいますと
この人も仙人なんですよ
それでもったいないということで
自分の妹の家に行って
そちらに 男の子がいてね
妹に で 行ってね 本当はこういうこと起きたんだと
王様のところで自分が今日子供を見に行ったところでもうなかなかの子供で
必ず真理を語るんだよと
でも残念なことに私はもう会えないんだと
ですから君はいかがですかと
その人の弟子として出家したらと
自分の甥に言って
その人はわかりましたと
自分のおじさんがものすごい仙人でしょうし
ですから おじさん言うことだからということで
その出家したんです お釈迦様はまだ子供なんですよ
赤ちゃんですよ その人はそれ聞いて出家して出たのは出たんだけど
でお釈迦様 それ３５歳で悟りを開いて
それでいろんなところで説法して
かなりインドで知られたようになったところで
その人になんとなく連絡入ったんですよ
ブッダがもう現れているんだよと
そこまでその人はもう１日１か所にしかいないという生活をしていてみたいです
誰ともしゃべれない 今日こちらでいたら
もう二度とその場所には来ないと
それぐらいの一人の生活をしていたんですね
だから一晩寝たところには二度と戻らないと
そういうことだから 人間関係もないでしょうに
その夜会った人とか なんとか挨拶ぐらいするかもしれませんだけど
朝になってくるとその人はいない
また別なところにいる
そこでその人々はどういう人かなとか知ろうとすると
もう別なところにいるんだから
だから彼にとっては人間と喋ることもできないし
人間関係を持つこともできない
それで何十年でしょうかね
もう一番悪い計算したっても
もう 30年間ぐらいでもかかったでしょうと思いますけど
例えばお釈迦様が生まれたという話を聞いて
仙人のおじ様に出家しなさいと言われて
それでもじゃあ今日やりますというではなくて
そのうち出家しますよと
5、6年間ためらっていて出家したにしても
もう30年経ってますよ それでその人もすごい年でしょ
そのナーラカという人が
もうボロボロ老人ですよ
で その人がまたとにかく話をなんとなく耳に入って
あっ ブッダが現れたんですから
では会いますと 言って お釈迦様に会いますよ
やっと会うのは この人が最初にブッダのために出家した人なんです
ブッダが赤ちゃんの時
やっと自分の先生に会うんですよ
そこでどれぐらい止まったと思います？なんのことなくブッダに会って
自分の質問を聞いて帰っちゃったんです
それで終わり もう二度と会わなかったんです
それスッタニパータにnālakasuttaというふうに記録はしている
意味はすごい深いんですよ
moneyyasuttaとも言いますけどね
ちょっと番号は覚えてないんですけどね
だから彼が彼なりの世界観を持っていて
もう人間と付き合うことはもう不可能
無理できない 今まで生きてきた生活
生き方はもう別に変えたくはないんです
それでお釈迦様はグループを作って
みんなと社会を作っていろいろ喋っているんだけど
本人が別にそれは気に入るわけじゃないんですよ
ブッダがいやってわけでもないんですよ
そこで自分の生き方があって
自分の概念があって 自分の見方があって
自分の哲学というものがあって
それはいかがなものでしょうかとブッダに聞かれたところで
ブッダが正しいやり方は正しい
moneyaと沈黙ということでね
で 沈黙っていうのは喋らない意味ではありませんと
ただ人と喋らない それで沈黙行者になるわけじゃないんだと
心が喋っているんだよと
ですから心がもう喋らないで
止まったことが本当の沈黙だよと
というふうに この涅槃悟りということも教えてあげたんですね
これが それでわかってわかりましたと
で 帰っちゃうんですよ
また二度と会わない だからその経典だけ勉強してね
それこそ仏教だっていうことは
それも仏教なんですけど
それこそということは言えるかと
そこでこのもう主婦というか
なんて娼婦というんでしょうか
このいろいろね もう女性の方々ね
いろいろ昔商売やっていたんだからね
そういう女性がいて 自分の体をみんなにいろいろもう貸したりしてね
生活していて 嫌だと こんな生き方というのは
いろんな変な人に会ったり
苦しい思いをしたりとかね
侮辱されたり けなされたりとかね
そういう生き方に疲れ果てて
で ブッダに会うと ブッダが語る仏教と
その人に 娼婦として生きている人が疲れ果ててブッダに会ったところで
ブッダが何か語ると その教えと
ナーラカ仙人に語った教えとぴったし同じくなるんでしょうかね
それ今から踏ん張って同じくならなくちゃあかんやと
これ失礼ですよ それでブッダのすごいところは
そういう学問もない 知識もない
修行したこともない 欲ばっかしの男性を相手にして
もう社会にすごいけなされて
ひどい目に遭わされていて
例えば男の人のやり方っていうのは
そういう女性にお金払って
もうサービスをもらいたい放題もらって
それから非難までするんですよ
けしからん人々だと社会に迷惑だと
だからもうそういう女性の立場から見たら
もうどう言えばいいんでしょうかね
自分たちにはもうこの社会で生きていられないんだから
もう体売ってでも生活しようとしている
それでもう誰かがお金を払ってくれて
その上また非難まですると
だからその人々の心にある悩みっていうのは
また別 すごい複雑で別なんですよ
だからその人にお釈迦様が真理の世界を語る
その場合 使う言葉と ナーラカ仙人に使った言葉っていうのは随分違います
違うんだけど 不思議なことは真理は同じ
ナーラカ仙人が沈黙って何なのかということで
いわゆるもういろんなことでもう煩わしいやと
人と喋ったり 仲良くしたり
付き合ったり これで心が汚れるんであって清らかになるわけがないと思っているんですよ
では私は喋りませんと
誰ともと自分で決める
2 日間 一箇所で止まっちゃったら
人間関係出来上がっちゃうでしょ
それ煩わしい だから私は一箇所にしか 1 日一箇所にしか泊まらない
本人が決めたでしょうに
それでも本人には でも何か違うんじゃないかなと
いくらか生活は楽なんですけど
なんかもう一つ清らかになったという気持ちがしない
それでブッダに会ったら
ブッダがいえ これがね
喋らないという意味ではなくて
喋ってもいいんだけど
心の沈黙だと 君の心が喋ってるんだよと
なんで心がずっと妄想したり喋ってるかというと
これ心が落ち着いてなくて
貪瞋痴があって 物に執着しているんだよと
体が執着してないかもしれません
だけど心が執着 同じ心理なんですよ
ですから 全てのものは無常であることを変化していることを
それをわかって何にもとらわれない心が作ったら
そこで思考しない心が成り立つの
これが沈黙だと これこそ聖なる沈黙やと
よくわかりましたと その人はこれ目指して頑張る
そこで娼婦の人が来たら同じことを言うんですよ
でも言葉遣いは違いますよ
人間っていうのは ただこの体が持ってるんだから
とにかく食べなくちゃあかんし
でも食べ物はないととにかく探し求めていくんだよと
体に服着ないとあかんしと
でもない場合は 何どんな工夫でもして服なんか探し求めるんだよと
それがすごく苦しいんだと
手に入らないんだと それでどんな工夫でもしようとするんだと
工夫して服やら食べ物を得たっても
なんかまた貶されたり非難されたりとか
またあるのは苦しみだけですよと
例えばもうおしゃれしたいと思って体を売っておしゃれをできるぐらいのお金をもらったっても
それでおしゃれして社会に出ちゃうと
またなんか なんかすごい気持ち悪いというかね
社会に顔を出して どうだい？私のネックレスは綺麗でしょうと言えないんですよ
あんた何をしてそれをもらった
儲かったんですかっていうことを心が聞いているんだから
だから生きるということはそういうことで
もともともう苦しくて 苦しみから脱出しようと思って踏ん張ったところで新しい苦しみが生まれるんだよと
そこで他の人々もそうでしょうと
わがままで 相手に対して何の親切もなくて
何の優しさもなくて 自分のことだけ
自分だけ納得すればいいやという人間関係を持っているんだと
だから自分でも苦しんでいて
社会でいろいろコンタクトを取ったっても苦しい
ですから これはもうとにかく何だかんでも生きていきたい
生きていきたいという欲から生まれるものだよと
その人にもそれなりの例を出しながら教えてあげる
それでそういう女性の方々
やっぱり自分にも道があるんだと
自分にも戻るべき家があるんだと
ブッダのところで これはもう腐りかけている体のことで
自分がちょっと社会で認めてない仕事をしているんだけど
やっぱりもう人間っていうのは心を清らかにする
清らかにするべきですよと
私だけ悪人で汚いことをやっているわけじゃなくて
みんな誰でも同じことで体の維持するために必死ですよ
だからみんなお互い様やと
そんなことはどうでもいいんだから
私はブッダに帰依して
ブッダの家が私の家だと
言って そこでブッダのところで心の家を探すんですよ
だからブッダの教えっていうのは
そういう風に この人に
人に合わせて 教えているんだけど
真理ねじ曲がったことはないんです
だから真理を語るためにどんなランゲージ
どんな言語を使いますかということなんですよ
それで私の説法にしたっても
東京でこういう風に喋りますけど
大阪に行ったらちょっと変えますよ
態度は すごく変わるんです
日本の他の地方に行ったら
もうみんなの顔を見て調子を見てもう態度変えるんですよ
だから同じ日本の中で
私は外人だから 標準語も変ななまりいっぱいありますけど
いい加減な標準語で喋ってますけど
大阪弁も喋れませんし
江戸の言葉も喋れません
なのにやっぱり話し方がそれぞれ地方で
それぞれ人々の顔を見ると変わるんですよ
それが違う言語ということなんですよ
だから同じ日本語ということになれないんですよ
で そういうことですから
この ブッダの問題というのはどんな言語を語るかということで
それでブッダのすごいことで
このそれ 我々はなんでブッダはそんなに唯一な存在ですかと
他にもたくさんいるんじゃないんですかね
悟った人々って ブッダの弟子たちとかね
サーリプッタ尊者やらモクレン尊者やら
もう 80人もいましたし
それから何千人も何万人もいましたけど
それでもみんなやっぱりお釈迦様
お釈迦様ということで
ブッダにすがってるんですよ
何なのかというと この能力なんですよ
言語の能力 表現能力 聞く人が持っている言語で語る
ですからわかると 自分の言語で語ってくれたと
その言語ということはまた誤解する可能性ありますけど
これはフランス語 ドイツ語
日本語 英語という問題ではありません
日本語一色にしたっても
それぞれ人によって言語を変えなくちゃあかんですよ
その意味で言ってるんです
単なる言語学の世界で言っている言語の意味ではないんですよ
そこで 20歳の人に語る日本語と 60歳の人に語る日本語は変わるんですよ
仏教を語る場合は だからブッダを理解するということは
このブッダのこの把握できないところ
理解できなくたっても
もうちょっと丁寧に見た方がいいんですよ
ですから 私がブッダを理解しているのは
私の言語で理解しているんです
他の人は その人を持っている言語で理解しているんです
そして私が片っ端からあんた方は間違っているとけなして言っちゃうと
これがもういい加減明らかにもう変ですよ
わかってないということになるんですよ
で わかった人は ブッダが複数の表現で
多数のことわざで 多数の表現力で
様々な言葉 様々な工夫をして同じ真理を語っていると
ですから 言葉ちょっと変わっても
仏教をわかっている人は同じことをわかっているんだということにはなるんです
そういうこの前の話ばっかりになりますけど
今日はもうテーマに入れないんですけど
ことだから ブッダに対してブッダはこの俗世間の人間の言葉っていうのは全く無視でしたと
無関心でしたというのは良くない話で
会う人に合わせて喋りました
ですから 健康は気になる人が来ると
それに対しても一言葉は言うんですよ
家庭のことを気になっている人が来ると
それなりに一言葉言うんですよ
だからそこら辺から見てみてみると
体のことと心の健康 体の健康と心の健康
あるいはタイトルから見れば
体の栄養と心の充実感という
ことにについても語ってますよ
でもそれが目的というわけじゃないんです
体の栄養について語るのは仏教の目的ではありません
それを誤解してほしくないんです
でも 体のことしか言語を持ってない人に
そういうふうに話してあげる
で これから一応テーマに入ります
体のことというのは 仏教ではこれから一般仏教学になりますので
それほど面白くないと
仏教学になってくると
お坊さんたちは全部まとめて揃ってしまっちゃうんですよ
個人個人に喋る場合はかなり力がありますけどね
仏教学になるとそれほどもうただの知識になってしまいますけどね
で 体のことどのように気にするかというと
4つの態度があるんですよ
4つのポイントがあるんですね
これが人間として 生命として生まれたらどうにもならん
4つなんです すごい みんな知ってます
これはえーと 衣 食 何でしたっけ？住
薬という 衣っていうのは服のこと
食っていうのは食べるもの
住っていうのは住むところ
薬っていうのは薬 衣食住薬ということで
仏教用語になっているんです
仏教用語になってくると
なんとなくちょっとつまらないというか
生き生きしてないんですよ
言葉は だから私はできるだけ仏教用語は避けます
できるだけ普通の日本で喋っている
あの  NHKで喋ってる言葉も使いません
生きてないんですよ カッコ良すぎて
だからカッコ悪い この普通の民間と言うんですか
テレビで喋っている日本語使ってますよ
これカッコ悪いかもしれません
品格ないかもしれませんです
失礼な単語かもしれませんですけど
生きていますよ 言葉は
とにかく それは置いといて
このだから私はできるだけ仏教用語とかパーリ語やら
避けたいと 避けられるところまでは避けますけどね
この何でしたっけ？衣食住薬という衣食住薬
衣食住薬という  4つがあるんですよ
これが 4つを2つにしてくださいとかね
これは無理でしょ これ無理です
じゃあ 4つを5つにしてくださいと言ったら
これは余計です だから仏教ではこのちゃんと世の中を見て
衣食住薬と 4つに分けてみたんですね
そこを分けた時点で 仏教はもう答えを出してますよ
世の中の人々に 分けた時点で経済活動やらいろんなことを言ってるでしょうに
政治やら経済やら これはあらゆる複雑で
勉強してもしてもしきれないほど
もう専門家だらけの世界で生きているでしょうに
何にしたっても専門家がいますよ
赤ちゃんのだっこの仕方聞いたらもう専門家がいるんですよ
それで結果はいつでも悪いと
いくら頑張っても そうやって世界が混乱している
服といえば もう一流のデザイナーがいるわ
いるわ でも誰一人ももう気楽に着られる服を作らないんですよ
みんな昔から使ってる
ごく一般的な服しか着ていないでしょ
だから何でしょうかと
日本にしたってモンペとか何とかありますね
あれ かなり便利で 家に戻ったら結構労働やらする方々だったらそれに変えるんだからね
決してフランス製でなきゃダメだとかね
イタリアのものでなければダメってことないんですよ
モンペって何なのかって
昔から使っていたものなんですよ
西洋的なズボンにしたっても
もう同じことで なのに世の中でどれほど服のデザイナーがいるかというとね
褒めることは崇め
称えることやらもう大変ですけど
ろくなことやってないでしょ
一般人のために 服は作るんだけど
もう恥ずかしくて着て社会には出られませんよ
だから特別な場でないと
特別な晩餐会とかね ああいう恥ずかしいところに出る時は
ああいう服を着て行ってもいいんだけど
まともな人間がいるところにはもうやめた方がいいでしょうに
日常の何か食べたいものとか飲みたいもので買う場合は
普通のコンビニに行くでしょうね
考えてください ブランド品ばっかしで
もう体も装飾してしまって
そちらに行っておにぎり買う時はね
というか 店にいる他の人にしたっても気持ち悪いんですよ
だから体の爪の先からもう髪の毛てっぺんまでブランド品で身を包んでいるんだったら
そういう変なところに行ってご飯食べてくださいと
この 110円のおにぎりを買ってはあかんと
で  110円のおにぎりは体に素晴らしい
健康的で決して悪くはないし
そういう人々はもう 1 万
2 万払って もう徹底的に体に悪い食べ物を食べなくちゃいけないし
だからとにかくそれはどうでもいい話なんですけど
一応衣食住薬の服にしたっても
もう専門家だらけの世界で
そこで経済やら自然破壊やら
もう何から何まで起きてあって
結局人間の役に立ってますかと
という問題があるんじゃないんですかね
だから混乱しています
ブッダから見れば 世界は混乱している
むちゃくちゃだと もうちょっと冷静になりなさいと
だから服は必要 不可欠
生きている間は これはもう不可欠なもので
だからといって何やってるんですかと
だからブッダから見れば
あなた方には不可欠な問題は服だよと
問題は 4つありますけど
1番目は でもそれも解決していないんだと
それさえも解決していないんだと言って
世界の人々は言うことを聞かないんだから
出家に教えてあげる 君たちだけでも聞きなさいよと
服って何なのかと ですから
出家は朝も晩も毎日念じる
観察する文章が一つあります
それは出家にしか認めてないんです
で 在家にはちょっと厳しすぎ
ですから在家の人々は観察する必要はないんですが
その分困ることになりますけど
出家は困りませんし ちょっと厳しくできている文章で
これは朝晩観察しなさいと
で 服というのは 体は寒さから暑さから守るためのちょっとした道具ですよと
それから虫とかね で それから感触の悪いいろんなものに体が触れちゃうと怪我したりするでしょ
そういうこの外の世界に体を触れて怪我したり
いろんなことを虫に刺されたり
いろんなのがありますから
そういうところからこの皮膚を守るためのものであると
いきなり 例えばものすごい激しい冷たい風が吹いたりしちゃうと
もう体が壊れちゃいますよ
それで体をこうやって服で隠してもらうと
そこで夏になってきて
強烈にもう太陽が当たると病気になっちゃうんですよ
体が弱いんだから それで服で
冷たい風も避けてもらって
熱い太陽を避けてもらって
一応ちょっとこの体を怪我しないように
病気にならんようにとちょっと守ってもらう
それから世の中で道徳というものがありますから
体っていうのはもうやたらに人に見せるもんじゃないんですね
ですから 体のいろいろ部品を隠した方がいいという世界の常識があるんですよ
ですから 体を隠しておけと
どうしても隠せないところがあるんですね
顔と 手のここら辺とかね
そこら辺だけ出しておけと
という目的で衣を着なさいと
ですから 出家が衣はこの目的に限るんだぞとはっきり言って着るんですよ
この世間に見せてはいけない
いけない部分を隠すために
冷たい風が吹いてくると
強い強烈な太陽が当たってくると
ちょっと体を隠すためにと
虫やらいろんなものに体が触れると怪我したり
いろいろありますから
そういうものから隠すためにだけ
それに限って 着ているんだよと
ということは観察していると
どれぐらいカットしていると思いますか？では
世間では何のために服を着ていますかとわかってますかね
だから仏教はどのように人を幸福にするかというと
それだけでもわかって覚えておいてください
それだけでどれほど生き方が楽になるかというと
服の目的 着物の目的を覚えておいてください
それだけでものすごい苦しみが消えるはずなんです
でも 欲に走っていて もう目的がない
とにかく走る 疲れ果てて死に倒れるまで走っている世界と
目的があってまっすぐ走る人とは違うんだから
で 服にしたら みんなとにかく開発する
とにかくデザインを変える
とにかく色を変えると
でも忘れているのは この体の健康
体を守ること それを忘れている
ですから 世の中の服の着方というのは
いかに美しく見せるかと
なんで自分をそんなに美しく見せなくちゃいかんですか？相手を騙すためでしょ
それで相手を騙して誘惑しちゃうと
相手に攻撃されるのは決まっているでしょうに
そうすると人に攻撃されないように
痴漢にあわないようにと
またいろいろなことをしなくちゃいけないんですね
私も商売するんだったら
もうなんて言いますか
綺麗な服を着る方々に
この体の上に何かつける電気の何か製品でも作ってあげたいんですよ
1万ボルトの そうすると誰が触ったらもう電気ショックを受けるんだから
痴漢防止用具として
そんなものを作っちゃうと
向こう側も電気ショック
を受けないようにと何か作るでしょうしね
で そうやってイタチごっこなんとかいうんで
そういう風に商売っていうのはもう行くんだけど
何バカバカらしいんじゃないんですか
結局は だからとにかく女性たちがもうものすごくもう派手にセクシーに見えることしか目指してない
服として そうすると決まってるでしょうに
このセクシーっていうのは
犬がああ 君ってすごいセクシーだなと
犬にかわいく認めてもらっても面白くないでしょうに
なんで非論理的ですかね
だから自分たちがすごい綺麗な
もうかっこいいセクシーに見える服を着たということは決まってるんですよ
男に認められるためでしょうに
家で飼ってる犬がああかわいいとは思わないんだからね
臭いと思うかもしれませんだけど
変な服だよと 犬っていうのは人間の匂いだけ嗅いでるんだから
ボロ服着た方が犬にとってはすごい気持ちいいんですよ
服にまで匂い付いてるんだから
これ あんまりにもかっこいい服なんか着ちゃうと
それぞれ材料は自分の匂いを持ってるでしょうに
人間にわからないんだけど
犬にとっては困るんですよ
着た服の匂いを引き算で引いて
人の匂いを感じなくちゃあかんだから
ですから とにかく美しい服を着るのは
家で飼ってる猫の犬の機嫌を取るためじゃないんですよ
世界中の男たちに認めてもらうためなんですね
それで男の人々はいくらか攻撃的に
攻撃的というか 攻撃的になってしまうということも決まっていることで
それが困ると では 攻撃防止対策をいろいろしなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そういう問題が余計に生まれる
それで終わらないんですよ
その女性たちの体 とにかく守られてないんですよ
丸出しだから 不健康だから
靴のなんとか随分もう 40センチ長くなっちゃうと
もう骨がね 曲がったり
いろんなことになっちゃうしね
だから結局何のために服かというと
体を守るために服でしたけど
これは体を危険にさらされるための服になってますね
ですから この攻撃を不幸を招く方向へ行ってますよ
そこら辺 仏教は厳しいことを言うんです
あなた方の考え方はおかしいんだと
論理的じゃないんだと
おかしいんじゃないかと
もともとはそういうことでしょう
体を守るための服ではないかと
今は体をもう攻撃させるための服になっていると
それで仏教 お釈迦様の教えを信仰する人々は
そこら辺では適度を知るということをするんですよ
そこで仏教はちゃんと出家
在家分けてますからね
きちんと分けてます ごちゃ混ぜにしないでください
在家は在家で 出家は出家で
そこで在家っていうのは社会生活しなくちゃいけない
商売であろうが何であろうが
人間との関係なんですよ
だから人間が自分のことを優しくかわいく思わない限りは
何一つもうまくいかないんですよ
自分が醜くてもうすごいかっこ悪くてダサいんだったら
その店にお客さんが来ないんですよ
商売っていうのは成り立たない
家族関係でも人間関係でも成り立たないということはあるんですね
だから在家の方々は 社会があって
社会の中で生きてなくちゃいけない
ですから 服の場合にしても
この出家とは違います
だから まず体を守ることを考えて
みんなにああ 綺麗じゃないかなと
というふうに 少々それなりに思われるぐらいの適度
知って生活すると あるんだから着るんじゃないんだよと
宝石あるんだからといってつけるものじゃないんだと
この適度知って どんな場で宝石使うか
どんな場で使わないかとかね
どれぐらい使うかと どんな服にするかと
だから自分とこの周り
自分がどんな社会に出るかということも考えて
そこら辺で違和感にならないように
派手に飛び上がっているような感じにもならないように
みんな少々機嫌が良くなるようなぐらいで
いればもう安全で平和で生きていられる
ですから そういうことは一般の世界では
服の場合は で 一番現代人が金をなくすのは服でしょうしね
これすごい非経済的で視線をみんな経済的と思っているんだけど
これ経済的じゃないんですよ
経済が崩れちゃいますよ
お金使いすぎだから だから困っているでしょうに
いくら頑張っても金足らないでしょうに
これ作っては売る 作っては売るということは経済的やというのは真理わかってない人々なんですよ
欲でいいんだと 欲で経済は壊れますよ
だからこの俗世間の経済学でみんな経済そのものを壊してますよ
それが仏教が言ってるすごい話なんですよ
みんな矛盾やってるんだと
長生きしたい したいと思って早死にすることをやっているんだと
健康でいたいと思って
瞬時に病気になることをやっているんだと
それで幸福になりたい
幸福になりたい 金持ちになりたいと思って
持ってる金もなくなる道を走ってるんだと
ブッダの言葉なんです
ですから ある面で俗世間の生き方
経済学にはすごいケチをつけてますよ
ある面で間違ってるんだと
これ矛盾の道だと だから経済学ダメですよと
正義はいらんやというバカなことを言わない
調整しなさいと 幸福の方向へ矛盾をやめなさいと
ただそれを言ってるだけなんです
なのに仏教を嫌いっていうのは
ちょっともう計算合わないんですよ
仏教は宗教じゃないんだから
人類誰でもブッダが教えたこの真理の道を実践してみると
自分で勝手にどんな宗教を信仰したってもいいんですよ
生きる場合は 朝ご飯食べて
昼ご飯食べて 仕事をして
夜もご飯食べて寝て生きてるでしょうに
その時はブッダが教えた通りにやってくださいと
信仰はどうでもいいんです
どんな神様を信じたってもろくなことないんだから
とにかく ですから この生きる時はこの矛盾なく生きてると経済というのは壊れません
そういうことですから
服は現代人というのはものすごい財産なくす世界であって
だからたくさん金が回ってるんだからと思って
それで経済が動いてるって
そんなことはないんですよ
結局壊れてやりきれなくなっちゃって
物が売れなくなったりとかね
としています で  2番目は食べ物ですけどね
同じことなんですけどね
食べ物は 出家の場合はそれはもう体持ってるんだから
ずっと食べなくちゃいけないんですね
出家には厳しくしているんですよ
この一日 生きていられるぐらいの量でしなさいと
明日の分まで今日食べるなよと
それでもう終了しますけど
問題は だからお釈迦様は厳密に見て
体からずっとエネルギーが消えていく
だから一日どれぐらいエネルギー消えるかっていうことは
人間っていうのは体でわかってますよ
でお腹も一応あの それぐらいの大きさでできてますよ
ですから 一日の栄養分だけ取っちゃうと
もうお腹には十分活動する場もあって
余裕もあって この栄養をちゃんと消化して体に与えてあげることはできます
人間どうですかね 胃袋は伸びますからね
伸びるようになってるんだから
これたくさん食うために伸びてるわけじゃないんですよ
それ忘れてるんです これ食べたものを砕いて砕いて
もう溶かさなくちゃあかんだから
そのためにこの臼の仕事をするために伸びたり縮んだりしているんですよ
伸びるもんだから もうとにかく詰め込む
そこ矛盾じゃないんですかね そうするとお腹に入った食べ物はもう砕いて叩かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
臼の仕事はなくなっちゃうんですよ
そういうことで もう栄養もはっきり消化もしていないし
消化していないものは腸に行ったら腐るでしょ
だから腐った食べ物 毒が入った食べ物が腸の中で流れているんです
毒が流れて腸が悪くならないと思いますか？
それで威張って我々には昔と違ってもう医学は発展しているんだよ
早期発見すればいいやといって
腸の中までカメラを入れたり
あらゆるまたもう道具やら工夫やら発展する
これ 無知な話じゃないんですかね
腸の中まで写真撮れる機械できたんだからって
威張る もうあれは恥じるべきものじゃないんですか？癌なんかはもう早期発見今できますよと
こういう薬飲ませて写真撮ればいいやとかね
こういう風にカメラ入れちゃえばよろしいやとかね
これまた体にそれほど痛くないようにも
新しい技術が発見しましたとかね
これノーベル賞までもらうんですよ
ノーベル賞じゃなくても追い出すべきですよ
世界からは これ恥じるべきものなんですよ
仏教から見れば なんで余計なものを食うんですかね？なんで胃に消化できないものを
胃はもうこれつぶしてすべて溶かさなくちゃあかんだからね
なんで溶かせないところまで食ってるんですかね
それで半分消化したものは腸に行ったらもう毒になるね
腐ったら毒ですからね
で 毒まで吸収する 細胞は死ぬ
そこは癌になる そこで体は維持するはずの食事は体にあらゆる病気を作ることになってますよ
現代人の病気って何ですかね？すべて食べ物からでしょ
高血圧もコレステロールも糖尿病も
腎臓病も肝臓であろうが
何から何まで だから健康のために食べると言いながら何やってますか？早死にするために食べてるんじゃないんですかね
だからそれ矛盾と言えないんですかね
だから私にも 私はブッダが使っていたことは
これは無知やと 無知はあまりにもかっこいいんだから
私はこのアホやと愚かやという言葉を使っているんだけど
これケチつけてるんですよ
私の言葉は失礼だと ブッダだったらすごい温厚というかね
すごい柔らかい言葉で喋ってるんだと
分かってるんですかね
ブッダの言葉っていうのは
パーリ語で読んでみなさいと
ドキッとしますよ 読めば読むほどえらい厳しいんですよ
ですから 一応無知という愚かという言葉を使わないように頑張りますと今日決めたんですからね
ですから あの そうやって健康のために体力をつけるために食べていて
それでわざと体力を崩して健康を崩す知識人の生き方
それはすごい知識的です
無知ではありません この矛盾であることはすごいかっこよくて頭がいいんです
ブッダは頭が悪いことにしてください
そこで頭が悪いブッダが
なんだおかしいやと言うんですよ
我々は正しいと思ってますけどね
だから人間の食べ方にしたっても
あの 矛盾になってるんですね
だから出家にお釈迦様ははっきり言ってますよ
もう  1日維持するためだけに食べてください
それ以上食べない それでもつい口に行くかもしれませんよ
食べ物は だから一つ観察するんです
この食べ物は体を維持するために入れるものであって
体力を作るためでもない
美しくなるためでもない
スタミナつけるためでも食べるわけじゃないんだと
食べないと体が苦しいし
でも余分に食べちゃうとまた苦しいし
ですから この今 空腹という苦しみが消えるところまで食べて
満腹で苦しまないところでストップするんだよと
空腹がなくなったらもう終わりと
で なんで食べるかというと
生きるために食べているのではないんだと
ただ死ななかったら修行できるんだよと
この無知なこの矛盾な生き方から脱出することはできますよと
ですから 修行するために
努力するために食べるんであって
生きるために食べているわけではないんだと
というふうなことを思って食べるんですけど
これが在家の方々には合わないんですよ
だから出家在家ははっきり区別しています
ですから 私たちは本当に正しく幸福でいたければ
食べるものの場合でも
もうちょっと知識的にならなきゃあかんということを言ってるんですよ
何のために食べるかと
体の栄養が消えていくだから消えている栄養はやっぱり入れてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
それだけしてあげればいいのに
で そこでこの見栄で食べる
あれも食べたことある
これも食べたことがあるという自慢するために食べる
これ大変悲しいことだと思いますけどね
味で形で食べる 誰一人も胃で食べてないんですよ
胃を馬鹿にしています
消化できるかないか こんなものを体の中に入れてもいいかないかということじゃない
なんて美味しい これフランス料理ではいただきますと
これは宮廷料理ではいただきますということで
だから時々いろんな国々の料理なんか紹介で
このある日見たんですよ
タイの宮廷料理 紹介するんだけど
余計に人間に煩悩作ってあげるんですよ
あんなものはタイの王様が食っちゃうと
もうとっくに死んでると思いますけどね
あんな嘘をつけちゃって
あまりにも豪華なもの
あまりにも残酷に料理作ったりしてね
すごいお金取ったりして
で それでいいのかと 本当に宮廷で王様たちって毎日あんなもの食べてますかね
あんなものを毎日食べちゃうと
もうどうなるんでしょうかね
でもみんなすごい健康でしょうね
例えばイギリスのエリザベスさんがもうすごい年でしょ
えらい元気なんですよ
何一つも病気がない もう我々生まれるともう女王でしたからね
で その50年代でしたっけ？ 1900
ちょっとね うん 今もいる
面白い話あるんですよ
今 あの今のイギリスの総理大臣って何でしたっけ？トニー・ブレア
で 彼が生まれる前にエリザベス女王なんですよ
だからその時の政府に対しても
女王が私の政府という風に
みんなに形式的に命令するんですよ
じゃあ頑張りなさいと
それ次の選挙で 次の人々が来たらと
それでブレアさんが来たら
もうブレアさんもあの女王の前で仕事をさせていただきますということで
宣誓をしなくちゃいけないんですね
今 イギリスを管理している人が生まれる前からも
エリザベス女王は国の王様なんですよ
いまだに元気で あんな豪華なものを毎日食べるとそうなると思いますか？だから晩餐会なんかは形式的にはね
大体食べないと思いますよ
気をつけています そんな知らない世界だからね
関係ない世界はどうでもいいんですけど
やっぱり我々はこの金を奪うために
あらゆる味で食べさせる形で食べさせる
見栄で 格好で食べさせる
なんとか王様を食べたものは自分も食べましたと
すごい気分がいいでしょうに
そうやって人に無知をとにかく引き起こして地獄に落としちゃうんですよ
そこでブッダが幸福の道を語っているだけで
あの おいしく食べなさいと
別に美味しくなくても
あれですからね 体を維持するためだけに食べたらいかがでしょうかと
あるんだからで食べるんじゃないよっていうぐらいで
この適度を知るということを仏教徒に教えるんです
次に住むところ
もう同じ論理でしょうに
住むところはやっぱりこの天気から
環境から体を守るために
昔からやっぱり住むところは必要です
夜寝ていると 寝ている時でも熊でも来て襲ったらね
虎でも来て食べてしまったら困るんだからね
ですから 一応どこかに身を隠して寝るということを
昔から人間が石器時代からでもやっていることで
で 本当はこれもいらんと思いますけど
動物っていうのは人間を襲わないんですよ
なんかまずいみたいで
人間の肉っていうのは
食べれたもんじゃないみたいですよ
動物は他の動物を襲いますけどね
人間は大体は襲わないんです
でも人間っていうのは動物を見ると怖いんですね
これ 人間攻撃するんだから
どうせ向こうは身を守るためにね
攻撃かけてくるしでないとあんまり攻撃しないんです
例えば 完璧に森の中に生活するんだったら
ヘビを踏んじゃって噛まれる可能性はあるんですけど
それ以外は獣に襲われるということはないんです
襲われません まずいしね
向こうは美味しい食べ物知ってますからね
で インドで昔 人間攻撃して
人間を食べる虎がいるということで
虎はものすごい殺されちゃったんですけど
やっぱり調べてみると
これは虎は人間食べない
攻撃もしないと で これでこの歯が落ちちゃって
それからこのハリネズミ
なんとかという動物がいて
あれ肉がおいしいみたいんですよ
これで虎なんかは見たら食べたくなるんですよ
ハリネズミは走りませんし
逃げませんしね で 噛もうとしちゃうと
このすごいきつい針は全部出しちゃって
この体に入っちゃって怪我するんですよ
その怪我は化膿になっちゃうんですよ
治療しない限りはもう
そうすると歩けない 虎は足なんかは
それから年取ってくると
この爪がこのなんかブラシ状態になっちゃうんで
先っぽが いくら研いでも研いても
それもすごい大きいんだから
猫と違ってね 猫でも年取ってくると
なかなか鋭さが消えちゃうんですよ
そこであの歯ブラシみたいなその爪で動物を掴めないでしょ
それで餌がないんだから
もうただ吠えただけで死にますから
人間っていうのはね 人間食べるようになっちゃうと
それもそのまま食べないんだそうです
ちょっと1日 2日 4日置いておいて食べるみたいですね
やっぱりまずいでしょうね
一度腐りかけちゃうと そんなにもうわからないんだからね
ということだからということで
今もインドではね
虎いるところやら
ライオンのところは あの
この何て言いますか この公園なんかね
見ている人々は平気で行くんですよ
全然攻撃も何もしない
毎日見ているしね とにかく人間とは
石器時代からとにかくもう住むところっていうのはありまして
で そこは我々はいかに住みにくい家を作るかということで
今頑張っていますね 今の家っていうのは大変で
管理維持はもう大変なんですよ
もう住む暇がないんですよ
家の管理で そこまで発展していて
高級なカーテンやら高級な壁紙やらいろいろ出てきちゃうと
料理はできなくなっちゃう
もしその煙なんかは高級な壁紙に吹いちゃうと
色が変わったりして
で 困りますからね それで
もし料理を作ったならば
もうまたもう壁紙まで洗わなくちゃいけないことになったりとかね
そんなの毎日やっちゃうとやりきれますか？とかね
ですから 結局はやりすぎというところは当然ありまして
で このバカでかい建物なんか作ってね
一代で終わってね それからお化け屋敷になっちゃうとかね
あるいはね もう残酷に日本でもすごい豪華な建物を壊すでしょ
この作った人がもう破産したりしてお金払えないとかね
これで 10億円  20億円で作ったものですけど
もう一旦もう １億円ぐらいでもう誰かもう新しい建物を作るんだぞってことで
それ全部そのまま壊してしまっちゃうでしょうに
だから何の馬鹿なことをやっているんでしょうかと
倒産もしないでしょうに
そんなことをやらなかったらね
そういうことで 我々は住むところも間違ってますね
だから仏教では適度を知りなさいと
子供 4人がいるんだったら
その分はちょっと家が大きくしたってもよろしいし
でも４人っていたってもずっといるわけじゃないんだから
そういう子供たちが家を出て行ってしまったら
また戻ってこないし それで老夫婦がどうやって大きい家の管理するかとね
だからそこら辺は適度にして
お前らもういいや 一人の部屋で生活しなさいと
机を分けなさいとかね
喧嘩しながらやっぱり苦労させた方がいいんですよ
どうせ大人になったら出て行くんだから
で 子供は自分に別な部屋が欲しいやと
私にも別な部屋が欲しいやと
で 子供３人に部屋３つ作ってあげたり
それで一人一人に道具いろいろ揃えてあげたりしちゃうと
親はやりたい気持ちはあるんだけど
後で大変なんですよ それよりはお互いに喧嘩しながら一緒にごろ寝して大きくなった方がいいんですよ
そこで大きくなっても
お互い兄弟には心配する
自分自分の家を作っても
なんか心配する すごくいい関係になりますよ
それで親の元の家はどうせ小さいんだから
親には年取っても家の管理はできる
そこでたまたま夫婦喧嘩したっても
家が小さいんだから実家に戻りますよと威張って戻ることもなかなかしないんです
ちょっと頑張ってみようとする
実家に子供二人連れて戻ってきたっても
実家が小さいんだからね
おじいさんおばあさんもいるんだからね
居心地が悪いんですよ
そうするともういきなり好き勝手に戻ろうとしないで
人生の苦しみにちょっとチャレンジしようともする
だからいいことずくめなんですよ
これで実家で結婚して子供三人いる娘さんにも
自分の家で自分の部屋はちゃんとあると
とんでもない話なんです
いつでも戻ろうとするんだから
そういうことですよ だから
この家が大きくなればなるほど
兄弟はお互いに仲良くしない
憎しみ合う 両親も兄弟
子供の気持ちさえもわからなくなっちゃう
あまりいいことはないんですよ
それで死にかけてくると
親を早く殺してでも財産を自分のものにしようとする
家があまりにもものすごい高価なすごいものだったらね
で 長男が自分のものにしたくなる
娘も自分のものにしたくなる
これでもう喧嘩になっちゃって
親を毒殺する可能性もあります
そういうふうな世界ですから
やっぱり適度を知った方が平和で幸せで生きていられる
4番目は薬 薬の場合でも
出家の決まりは病気になったならば飲みなさいと
それ以上使ってはいけませんと
はっきり決まってるんです
薬自体が毒ですよ で 体に何か異常があって
これ攻撃するでしょ ですから
体に異常がない場合は
もう体に入れるもんじゃないんですよ
で インドの習慣というのは薬飲まない方が正しいと
でもそれで何しますかと
1ヶ月間に1回ぐらい体を洗うんですよ
中を 食べ物をいろんなものを残して毒が残ります
それで薬やります 薬と言ったっても薬草いろいろものですけどね
そういうものは月1回は飲んで食べないでいる
水ばっかり飲んで そうするとなんかえらい洗濯したような感じで
もう全部体が洗ってしまうんですよ
で またおかゆを食べて
それからまた普通の食べ物に戻ると
そういうことを月1回やると
もう病気にならんと思いますけどね
それは昔のやり方で 今はそういうことはしませんし
とにかくそれは関係ないでしょうし
で 仏教の出家に言ってるのは厳密的なところで
病気になったらその病気を治すためだけ薬を使ってくださいと
で なきゃ使わないということで
で それも人間の世界になってくると
薬っていうのは商売でしょ？経済でしょ
これは人の病気治すためではなくて
この巨大なスケールで経済活動する仕事なんです
もう病気は関係ないんで
死んだってもどうでもいいんです
金さえ儲ければ 人はどうでもいいんですよ
すごい高い機械買ってきたんだからね
それにお金払えと だからいらないと言ったっても
強引に入れてくれるんですよ
機械の中に で それで病気わかるかというとわからないんです
例えば人間ドックにいくら行ったって病気発見できないでしょうに
そういうふうなことになっています
だから人間ドックというのは
理想的に言えば早期発見のためのもんですけど
それはそういう目的じゃなくて商売ですよ
ですから お客様だからすごい機嫌よくしてあげて
なんとか何とかチェックをさせて
で もう感謝して帰させるんです
もう異常なしと 次の日
病院に行くことにもなるなるんですけどね
病気になって病院に行ったら同じ機械でチェックしますよ
その時はちゃんと発見します
これちょっとおかしいんですけど
とにかく今の世界の治療というのは
もう病気ということではないでしょうに
なんかもう商売の世界になっていて
それでなかなかお金かかりすぎて
もう今治療っていうのは万人にできないんですよ
すごい金持ちでないと治療を受けられないんですよ
病院はものすごい設備
完璧なものっていうのは
最新技術とかね あることはあるんだけど
みんなにそのお世話をしてもらうことはできませんね
だから一つの商売になっているしね
だからそれで人間っていうのは
結局病気を治すための治療方法なんですけど
それだけはやってくれない世界になっているんです
今はお金がある人の ちょっと時間余裕があると
ちょっとお遊びに行くとこなんですよ
贅沢のお遊びですよ そういうところですから
そちらでも仏教は適度を知るという
適度っていう場合は
薬の場合は病気になったら適量な薬を使うと
それで終わると そこで私たちも人間っていうのは病気になった時点でもう失敗だと
間違いだと 病気になったら
自分のもう生き方がもう間違ってるんだということだと
ですから 病気になること自体が恥ずかしいやと
そういうことで 適量に食べて
適量な運動で適量に生活すればいいんじゃないかなと
それでも病気になる時はなりますから
これはもうどうにもならんことで
で 病気になったっても
恥ずかしい病気にだけはなってほしくないんですよ
高血圧とかね 心臓発作とか
そんなのはもう恥ずかしいんですよ
もう70歳で80歳でいきなり心臓発作で死ぬんだったら
これはもう寿命だからね
それはありがたいんですね
ぽっくり死んじゃったと
これ 20歳になってなる時でも
何々病という 何でしたっけ？成人病っていうものにかかりますからね
そこで遺伝とか何とか言い訳するんだけど
遺伝も親だからね 親から恥ずかしいことをやってきて
遺伝っていうのは変わるんでしょうに
同じ遺伝子じゃないんだからね
だから遺伝やらなんとかと言ったっても
そういう風にも甘いことって言えないと思いますね
だから病気になること自体も恥ずかしいと思って生活すればどうですかね
そういう風にこの体っていうことは守られます
あまり派手には言ってないんですけど
この適量に食べること
食べ物に執着して ああ
おいしい ああおいしいと食べないことは
仏教はすごいかっこいいと思ってますよ
今 NHKで流れている朝のドラマっていうのは
あれは正真正銘の仏教はものすごく嫌う世界なんですね
そこまで苦労するべきかと
全く反対の世界を見せてくれるというかね
そこまで死にそうに食べるものに
苦しみますかと こんなものは簡単単純で得られればいいのにね
でも あのドラマの中でも私は気に入っている部分がありますよ
なんとか尼さんの場面がありまして
もうなんかいろいろ仏教的なことやらいろいろ
そこら辺すごい立派なことを言ってましたしね
そこら辺はちょっといいことを言うなと言ってるなという気には入ってましたけどね
そこまで苦労するべき
これは日本のね 日本の世界の感情
感覚ですから 苦労しなきゃかっこ悪いと
だから この NHK の朝のドラマっていうのはいつでも同じテーマでしょ
もう苦労して苦労して
苦労してやっとって これをやったってとこは大したことないんですよ
普通に落ち着いたと
この普通に落ち着くための道順の長さと苦労しみっていうのはね
これみんなありがたがってるんですね
もうだから悪口で言えばね
もうそんなにも苦労する必要あるんですかと
もうね アホじゃないかということも言えないわけでもないんですけどね
簡単に生きていればいいんじゃないかと
とにかく食べ物に対しても
いろんなものに対してね
そうやってもうあまり余計にひどく苦労しないで適度を知るということは
ブッダが教えて それで幸福になりますと
それで経済システムは倒れません
そういうシステムだったら
いくら人が生まれてきたっても
人口はもう増えて困るということは成り立たない
そうすると 避妊 なんとか薬とかにして
女性たちというのは大変でしょうに
もう恐ろしいものを食べたり飲んだりしなくちゃあかんだから
男はいいんだけど この避妊の薬とかね
あんなものはもうずーっとなんか 1ヶ月間ぐらい飲むみたいでしょ
あれで大丈夫かなと だからもう私は一人で
普通の薬でも嫌がるんだから
私はね もうあまりにも我慢できないほど頭痛なんかしちゃうとバファリンぐらい飲むんですけど
でなきゃえらく嫌がるんですよ
そういう気持ちの人から見ると
こんな薬なんかね もう飲むようになるとね
だからもう本当にみんな被害者で
この世界システムそうなってるんだから
そういう薬飲まなくちゃいけないことになる
妊娠したら困ると言って
せっかく幸福に生きるために生まれてきたのに
なんですかね その体を壊さなくちゃいけない
体に毒を飲ませなくちゃいけないと
それが幸福という この頭の良さっていうのは驚きですよ
毒を飲んで体を壊しながら
もうプロポーションとかスマートになるためにといって
もうあらゆる苦労しながら
服に体を合わせて生きながら
これこそ幸福 仏教なんかあっちへ行って暗いやと嫌やととかなんかいうところはまた面白いんですよ
だから仏教はなんか変なことを言ってますけど
これは でも残念ながら事実なんですよ
人間っていうのは矛盾で不幸な道を選んで幸福になるんだぞと言っている
お金がなくなる道を選んで
これで金儲かるぞという
もう賭け事に行ってる人と同じなんですよ
私は億万長者になるぞと
どんな方法で？宝くじに当たってと
宝くじが当たって億万長者になる
と言って だからこの毎週でしょうか
わかりませんだけど 毎月か
もうそれでずっと もう何万
何十万円の宝くじを買うと
これで金持ちになるんですかね
それで悪く言ったら 何ような当たったらどうしますかねと
それでまた反発もするんだからね
だから この俗世間のそういう生き方は良くないというところですね
そこでちょっと休ませていただいて
心のところに入ります
心の場合も心の栄養とタイトルを書くべきところなんですけど
一応答えとして 心の場合は栄養というよりは充実感という方がいいということにしているんです
で 体の栄養と心の栄養と書けば単純でいいんですけど
心の栄養っていうのは心の充実感なんですよ
だからそれは答えです
結論でそれで終わったってもいいんです
だから この我々 なんで体まで経済まで世界まで壊しているんでしょうかと
なんで自然破壊して自滅というんですか
自己破壊するところまで人間が頭が良くて頑張ってますかと
あらゆる研究 学問すべてどこを目指しているかというと
自己破壊を見ているでしょうに
なんでそんなことやる？それで幸せになるんだぞと
という話でしょ 俗世間の話っていうのは
ですから 出家から見ればすっごく面白いんですよ
この何やってるかって見ているところはね
そこをなんでそうなるかというと
心に充実感がないんですね
だからもう何でも破壊する
食べてももう足らんと思っちゃう
もっと美味しいものを食おうではないかと思っちゃう
それで世界が壊れてしまう
結婚したっても やっぱりあの女の人もっとかっこいいなと思っちゃうと
もうこれで人生終わってしまうと
これ何でしょうかね
だからどんな宗教 どんな哲学者が
どんな政治家がもう何言おうが
この世の中は不幸になるのは決まってるんですよ
誰と結婚したっても もうどういう子供が作っても
どんなところで就職して仕事あったっても
不幸になることもう決まってるんですね
理由はもう今まで説明したこの体の問題で
衣でしたっけ？衣食住薬という問題にしても
これむちゃくちゃ混乱して壊れているのは
もう結局は心に充実感がない
だからその1ポイントでとってほしいんですよ
頭で捕まえなさいと 根元から
だからこの中部経典でひとつ蛇の経典がありましてね
その経典の中に言ってるのは
蛇はもう首で捕まえなさいよと
それで幸福やと なぜならば
蛇はもともと猛毒を持っていて
いい加減尻尾の方で触ったり
ちょっと体の真ん中の方で触ってみたりしちゃうと
もう噛まれて死んじゃいますよ
でも本人がこの怖い蛇を捕まえたいんですよ
捕まえて  なんて言いますか
このコブラのことだと思いますけど
コブラを見せて金儲けてるでしょ
この蛇使いとかね それ見てお釈迦様が作った経典だと思いますけどね
インドでは今もいるんですよ
いろいろ道端にストリートパフォーマンスという人々が
コブラ捕まえて で
何かに入れて それからこのなんとかこの笛を鳴らしながらコブラを遊ばせて見せて金もらって生活しています
そこでインドの場合はそういうカーストがいるんですよ
蛇使いというんでしょうかね
蛇使いって別に蛇には調教するわけじゃないんですけどね
あれ 我々騙されてるんですよ
なんかこの蛇使いの人とか
これはみんなにできませんと
このコブラなんかね 野生の動物を取って
それからちゃんと踊れるように訓練させてとか
全然何もやってないんです
で 別にコブラ遊んでるわけでもないんですけど
それはいいんですけど
そのカーストなんですよ
そのインドの昔の そのカーストの人々はこの蛇を使って生計を立てなくちゃいけないと決まってるんです
農業なんかやってはあかん
誰も土地をあげません
ですから その蛇使いの人々にとっては
いくら猛毒やといっても
蛇を捕まえなくちゃあかんですよ
でなきゃ生きていられません
だったら尻尾で掴むなよと
胴体で取るなよと 頭で捕まえなさいと
頭で捕まったらもう蛇にはどうすることもできないし
で 蛇っていうのは餌もらったらもう人誰も攻撃しませんだからね
恐ろしくこの驚いちゃうと
なんて言いますか 刺しますけど
でなきゃもう襲いません
ですからコブラをとって
もう何か卵でも飲ませちゃって
それで箱に入れておくんですよ
グーグーと寝るんですよ
1週間でも それであの
いきなりは開けません
もしあの箱にちょっと音を出して叩いて
振動を起こしてコブラに起きてもらって
それで箱を開ける もう蛇っていうのはもう簡単に人間に
馴染むんですよ 向こうは冷血動物だから
人間が触っちゃうと気持ちいいんですよ
暖かいんだから 人間の体は
だから猛毒のコブラでも
もし手に慣れてしまえば
もう体中もうとぐろ巻いてあちこちどこでもいるんです
蛇にしたら 人間というか
何か気持ちいい木 枝ぐらいでしょうね
あんまり生命だと見ているかどうか分かりません
だけどネズミだったら生き物やと思うかもしれませんだけどね
ですから 蛇に慣れるということは
この虎と馴染むことほど大変なことじゃないんです
一日でもあればいいんですよ
だから自分の大学でも教授がいて
この蛇は専門ですけどね
どんな蛇でも何のことなく手で触っちゃうみたいんですよ
どんな蛇でも 猛毒の蛇でも取ってポケットに入れちゃう
何の手袋でもなんでもない
そこで取ったばっかしのバイパーとかコブラよりも機嫌が悪い
蛇もいますよ で 何のことなくポケットに手を入れてまた出したりする
出しても 蛇がこうやってぐるぐる回ったりして噛まない
これはもう知ってます
その人は蛇のプロだからね
もうこの爬虫類っていうのは
やっぱり体の温かいってことわかったらね
もう何のことなく居心地がよくいるんです
とにかくそういう人々はそれで蛇をね
見せて みんなに見せて
いくらかお金もらっちゃうと
だからその経典はポイントは違いますから
今日は言いませんですけど
やっぱりどんな問題でも根元から取るというのは仏教のやり方なんですね
このガチャガチャはもうしないんですよ
ややこしくしない だから
この もう私はすごく嫌だとみんな思っているのはそういうわけだと思いますけど
こちらはもう曖昧であまりYESとも言わないし
ノーとも言わないし どっちですかと言えば
こんな言われたってもどっちでもないんですよと言っちゃうし
そういう思考と仏教というのは結構違うんですよ
そんなどこまであんた曖昧でいるんでしょうかと
はっきりしなさいっていうのは仏教の立場
例えば 人とちょっと仲が悪くなったと
だったらもうこれっきりにもう縁切りするか
少々あったとしても
ごめんなさい また仲良くしましょうとするか
どちらかでしょうに その方が一日でも早く問題解決するでしょ
それはしませんね 延々と死ぬまで
なんか嫌な関係も仲がいいともわからないし
悪いともわからないし
もうずっと持っていっちゃうんですね
だからそういうこととは
仏教の見方というのは違う
はっきりしましょうと
今日死ぬかもしれませんしね
だからこのもうこれでは困ると
一日でも幸福に生きてなくちゃいけないと
だからはっきりしてほしいというところはありますね
だから 今日のポイントから見ても
とにかく問題はすぐ根元から捕まえると
というのは 一つのこの仏教的な立場で
で これが事実でないならば言ってみてください
例えば もう人間がもう神様
何でもいいんですけど
そういう変な神秘的なことを言うんだったら
これは証拠ないでしょうに
本当か嘘かわからないんですよ
神が創ったかないか もうさっぱりわからない
信じる方々は一生懸命信じているかもしれませんだけど
信じたんだからといって
それでも証拠は出てこないし
ですから そういうこの微かにでも曖昧な態度は
仏教は嫌なんですよ ブッダが嫌なんですよ
はっきりしましょうと
だからどんな問題にも仏教は答えを持ってますけど
みんなそんなこと言ったら困りますよ
商売は崩れますよということで
もうまたけちをつけようとするんですよ
本当に仏教を聞くと かなりいろいろシステム変わっちゃいますよ
いい加減なことはもうやめます
みんな ですから この問題の場合は
なんで世界がおかしくなっちゃって
生きていられなくなっちゃって
で 健康を維持して長生きにしてくれるはずの食べ物は
寿命は短命にして病気を作ってくれるし
気楽に穏やかに住むために作った家が自分の頭にぶつかる
もう何て言いますか
壊れてくると だって家のローンがもう30年でしょうに
これでどれほど困っているかというとね
家で潰されているでしょうに
本当は潰されるための家ではなかったはずなんですけど
服で潰されてるでしょうに
だからそこは何なのかといえば
これが心が充実していない
納得していない 喜んでないんですよ
みんな 嘘でしょ 言ってるのは
人生は楽しいと 仏教は暗いと
本当かと 嘘ばっかりで自分たちの生き方が暗いんですよ
笑えないし それは仏教のせいにする
だから頭の悪いことに私に文句言ってくること
いつでも口に来るんですよ
あなたの頭の悪いのは私のせいではありませんと
書きたくなる場合いくらでもありますよ
だからそうやって人に何とか言うと
私も人がね ちょっと気が立つことをわざわざ書きますけど
とにかくこの私たちはこの心の充実感というものは持ってない
だから自然までいろいろ壊して壊していく
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
やっぱり 1 秒  1 秒しか生きてないでしょ？人間っていうのは
だから何秒生きてるかっていうことは
いくらかは決まっている
何回食事するかっていうことはもう決まっている
そこで今日の朝はなんか朝ごはん食べようとしたでしょうに
で そうするとあったのはもう賞味期限は 1 日も経っている
2 日も経っている食べ物何かかもしれません
でもそれしか食べ物はないと
だったらどうしますかね？それ捨てて何も食べないで我慢するか
それ一つの道なんですよ
これは 1 日経ってますから
もう食べませんと あるいはもう 1 日経ったぐらいはね
もう食べ物っていうのは別に
何といいますか 英語ではノンリバールというんですけど
食べてはいけないってことではないんですよ
1 日 2 日経ったってもね
一応法律で決めているだけ決まってるだけで
卵買ってきてちゃんと賞味期限書いてるでしょ
では次の日食べてみてください
死んだら言ってください
責任持ちます ですから
これは今日で卵の日にちが終わると言ったっても
次の日でも次の日でも
これは食べられますよ
で それで自分がそれ食べるか
あるいは嫌だと言って食べないでお腹空いたままでいるかということなんですよ
私がどちらでもいいと言っている
言いたいんですよ どちらでもいいんです
それは捨てて お腹が空いたままで昼まで我慢する
あるいはそれを食べると
どちらにしても満足しなさいと
充実感感じなさいと でなきゃ
もうお釈迦様が使った言葉は言わなくちゃあかんですよ
もう今日は使いません
そこで 朝ごはんっていうのはもう何回食べるかっていうこと決まってるでしょ
1日1回でしょうに それで朝ごはん食べて
もっと美味しいものを食べたかったのにと思うことは論理的ですかね
それで頭は素晴らしいと言うんですかね
これもう繰り返せないでしょ？リピートできないでしょう
これでもうおにぎり食べようが
もうもう 2日経っている豆腐食べようが
もう私みたいに 2週間経ってる食パン食べようが
これはもう 私は美味しく食べますよ
今日焼き立てのパン食べたかったと一度も思ったことがないです
焼きたてある場合は焼きたても美味しいなと思いますけど
これは 2週間経ってきて
そろそろカビも もう
臨終と何て言いますか
することになった 別にどったことない
もうこれはちょっと焼いて食べればいいんじゃないかって
これは美味しいと思うだけのことなんですよ
ですから この朝ごはんの場合は
これはもう食べるんだったら1回きりでしょうし
2回リピートできませんし
だからそれで満足しない人ほど
非論理的なおかしい人がいるんですかね
ですから 食事のまずいか
こんなことどうでもいいんですよ
この日でそれしかないんだから
ここら辺はほんのちょっと論理的になるだけ
リピートないんですよ
人生に 誰かの結婚式に行くとします
それでもう自分がいろいろ服なんか調べたところで
もうなんかもうちょっと古いというかね
ちょっとあの手入れやらドライクリーニング出し忘れたとかね
あるかもしれませんよ
そこで何かアクセサリーもあったんだけど
もう誰かに貸してあげちゃって
ちょっと戻ってもらわなかったと
それだったらあるもので行けばいいんですよ
もうそれでリピートできますかね
その じゃあ今度はその人の結婚式にちゃんと準備して行くぞと
もう1回きりでしょうに
だからそこでこれでいいんじゃないかと
これしかないよと 自分がもう最高なことをやってるんだよと
それだけでしょうに 例えば服があるんだけど
その服に似合う帽子もあったと
帽子が誰かに子供かもう娘さんか
持って行っちゃって
もうなんかもう返してこないとかね
でお母さんがもうこれでなんでしょうかね
だから帽子なくてもいいでしょうに
それで服を着て結婚式に行く
行ってもそのお母さんが
自分がもう最高に頑張って結婚式に行ったんだと
あ なんで帽子があった方がかっこよかったのに
帽子があった方がかっこよかったのに
言ったっても そのお母さんが自分持ってるもののギリギリのところで頑張ってるでしょうに
なんであんな変なことを考えてるんですかね
買った時 帽子も付いていたんだとかね
これ 娘がもう気に入っちゃって持っていっちゃって
なかなか返してこないんだと
持っていくんだったら服まで持っていけばいいのに
これは古いんだと持っていかないんだと
と こういうことはもう家で面白く子供と遊んだっていいんだけど
やっぱり結婚式に行ったらこれリピートできないでしょうに
だから自分がもう最高なことをやっているんだと
だから 2週間経っている食パンを焼いて食べている時でも
私は最低なものを食べているわけじゃないんですよ
自分持っている最高なものを食べているんですよ
それでブッシュさんだったら
朝ごはんもっとすごいことを食べるんではないかとかね
小泉純一郎さんだったら
もうめっちゃすごいものを食べてるんではないかとか
こんなことどうでもいいでしょうに
ですからもう食パンはまずかったんだから
今度もう一回やり直しとやり直せますかね
だから人生にはやり直しはない
やり直しあるんだけど
それは別な意味で 時間論で考えればやり直しはないんですよ
一回きりで それでだいたいの人間っていうのは精一杯頑張ってるはずなんですよ
大体は そこで朝 では豆腐でも食べようかなと思ったところで
豆腐 2つあるんだと もう1つは 2週間も経ってるんだと
忘れちゃって 1つは昨日買ってきたもので
誰が食べるんですか？ ２週間経っている豆腐は
その場合は それでも食べますか？食べないでしょうに
当たり前 決まってるでしょうに
ですから 昨日買ってきた豆腐を作って食べるでしょうに
２週間のものはもういらんとゴミ箱に捨てるでしょうに
だから人間というのはいつでももう最高なことをやってますよ
昨日買ってきた豆腐あるにも関わらず
２週間前の豆腐を食べるというならば
それはもう頭がいいことで
でもみんなそんなことをやってるつもりで
不満で生活しているんじゃないんですか？だから今日こちらに来る時着た服も
この場においては自分たちが最高なものは着ているんですよ
今日の勉強会にはもうやっぱりあれが着てきた方がよかったとかないでしょうに
今日はこれでいいやと
だからもう人間っていうのは日々最高なことをやって
最高な生き方しているのに
この態度って何ですかね
もっと美味しいものを食べたかったとかね
もっといい人と結婚したかったとかね
これだから言ってますよ
人間っていうのはひとかけらも理性がないんだと
ブッシュさんが何食べようが
もう関係ないでしょうに
ですから もう我々は日々充実感するのは当たり前で
論理的で 貯金が 1,000万になってから充実感を得るぞと思ったら
永久的に得られないでしょうに
貯金は 3 万しかないと言ったっても
その人の最高なレベルですよ
それが なんでそれで満足しないんですかね
ですから この私たちは
これがもし脱線しちゃうと厳しいことを言いますけど
もう 3万円しか貯金がない人
それで満足するということは
それでいいということですか？とかね
もう明確に屁理屈を見せますけどね
それだったら だからそういうこと
これを時間論で語ってますよ
時間論で 我々の命が 1 秒 １秒ずっと過ぎ去っているんですよ
ですから その各 1 秒で満足しなさいということなんですよ
だから今の貯金はもう 3万円でしょうと言ったら
この 1 秒で自分が最高な位置にいるんですよ
そこでどんどん努力していったところで
もうある日で 1,000万貯金あるかもしれませんだけどね
でも 1,000万貯金になったところで
昔は貧しかったとかね
いろいろ苦労しましたとかと思っちゃうとバカもいいところでしょうね
ですから 昔も良かった
今も良かったと 明日も良かったと
という生き方 満足の充実感の生き方なんですね
これが心の充実感 それさえあればもう何の問題もない生き方なんですよ
簡単単純でしょ それが
我々はもうちょっと理性的になるだけ
大したことじゃないんですよ
人間に実行できない 実践できない
もう雲の上の話をしているわけじゃないんです
いわゆる我々は過去1秒で最高なことをしている
最高なことをしてないともうとんでもないろくでもない人間だから
それも今日はすごい怠けは嫌でしょうし
努力しないことはとんでもない嫌やと思っているし
ですから その1秒で1秒で自分がもうこれは最高やということで
生きていなくちゃいけないでしょうに
今日私は駅からタクシーで来ようかな
バスで来ようかなと思っていたんですよ
どうせ遅くなってるんだから
じゃあタクシーの方がいいやと思ってはいたんだけど
もうバスが来ちゃったんですね
だからタクシーは別な
例えば寄り道で早く行くんだったらタクシーに乗る方が時間的には有利ですけど
同じ道路だからね バスであろうが
タクシーであろうが 同じスピードで
その場合は同じ信号の数でしょ
だったらバスに乗りますと
乗ったのはいいんだけど
バスが動かないんですね
今日は あ 失敗しましたという気持ちもあったわ
正直なところはね で お金も払ってるんだからね
また降りてタクシーに乗っちゃうと
やっぱり失敗ということになるんですよ
とにかく で 向こうは時間調整のためにも結構待たされたんですけどね
別にそれで あれやってやればよかった
これやればその時に いいんじゃないか
バスに乗ったんだからね
バスがそこを そのうち行くんだからね
そんなときはありますと だから
その自分がタクシーがあって
バスがあって バスに乗ろうと思った瞬間
判断がその時の自分のいい判断なんですよ
後の状況を見れば 判断間違った
もうどうしようもないでしょうに
今悩んだって戻りはできませんしね
戻れば戻るほど悔しい思いが増えますから
私は戻りません その場合は
ですから この人間というのは後から失敗やなんとかと思ったっても
こんなのはちょっと理屈の間違いであって
この決断した瞬間では
一番いいものだと思って決断して行動しますよ
ですから 後であれは失敗です
そうなんですよ 後で結果見たらあれは間違ったんですけどと
それだけで終わればいいんでしょうに
ということで 世界を破壊しないで
自分の人生を破壊しないで
周りを破壊しないで それから
生まれてから死ぬまで幸福でいたければ
この秒単位の充実感を味わうしかないんです
それは心の構え方で それで人生は幸福になるんです
ブッダが説く幸福はすごい具体的なものなんです
楽しく生きていられます
だから 俗世間でいう金があれば幸福
健康であれば幸福って
こんな条件付きの幸福っていうのはほとんど得られないもんなんですよ
金があれば幸福という人には今すでに金がないでしょ
ということは 金儲ける技を持っていないということなんですよ
ということは 死ぬまで幸福にならんということなんです
健康であれば幸福という人が生き方はまずいでしょう
だから今不健康だからね
これからも不健康ですよ
幸福になりません だから明日幸福があるぞという明日があるさとみんな歌ってるでしょ
みんなもう不幸のどん底
本当に幸福な人は明日がないさあと歌うべきなんですよ
これくらい明日がないさ
それが明るいでしょうに
だから楽だから 明日がないんだから
それ暗いと言っちゃうでしょうに
明日があるさと言った途端
今日はダメということでしょうに
今日は失敗でダメやと悔しいと
まあいい 明日があるんだからと
ですから 明日があるさっていうのは仏教的な考え方じゃないんです
それは充実感について
それぐらいのことを考えておいてください
すごい簡単です ものすごい単純簡単です
1秒の論理で生きてみてください
で だからこれちょっとごまかしではなくて
このいろいろごちゃ混ぜにしないでください
貯金見たらもう 100円しかなかったらまあいいんじゃないかというのが私の言い方で
100円もあるんだよと
そこで満足する 自分の精一杯だから
それはもう 100円だけで十分
永久的にという意味じゃないんですよ
だから 日々 瞬間瞬間 精一杯頑張れば
もうなるようになるでしょうに
だから 100円は 1 000万円に伸びても
100円  100円のまんまで
死ぬまでいたっても 人が幸福でいてほしいという論理なんです
不幸にだけなるなよと
100円の貯金がずっと死ぬまで 100円のままで
あるいは 100円の貯金がどんどんどんどん伸びていって
1 000万円で止まったとか
どっちでもいいんです
それと心の幸福充実感というのは別に考えてほしいと
もう一つ 心の栄養といえば
心の栄養というのは心がいろいろ刺激欲しいんですよ
で 体大体生きているということ
この刺激のことで我々はご飯を食べて
心に刺激を与える で 体がなんかもうお腹がすいたりすると心に刺激が入る
するとご飯を食べて刺激を与える
音を聞いて心に刺激を与える
だから本当に栄養が必要なのは心なんですよ
体っていうのは物体で機械でどうったことないんですよ
で 世界は体大事だと思ってますけど
そんな体大事じゃないんですよ
体を通して我々は心を
おだてているんです 目を通していろんなものを見て心を喜ばせているんですよ
舌を通していろんなものを味わわせてあげて
心を喜ばせているんですよ
耳を通して だからお腹を通して
だから心っていうのはものすごい
このもうキリがない欲ですよ
だから我々は食べる時失敗する
ものを見る時失敗する
音を聞いて失敗すると
だからこうやって この限りのない欲の世界を作っています
地球も足らなくなるほど欲が大きいんですね
問題は心にあるんですよ
だからちょっとおにぎり 1個食べさせてね
体に それでそれは美味しいやと思って心が満足すればいいところで心が満足しないんですよ
だからおにぎりではなくて
他のものを探していく
他のものを買って食べるぞと思って店に行ったら
店はまだまだ開けてないとかね
あるいは品切れと それでまた悔しくまた戻ってくるとか
そういうふうにいろいろトラブルが起こるんで
だからこの心ということは大事にしなくちゃいけない
この悪人が心なんですよ
我々 体じゃないんです
体はどうでもいいんです
心の奴隷なんですね
体が ですから
俗世間では体ばっかり気にしているんですけど
仏教は全然気にしない
ですから この心の刺激ということを勉強してほしい
だから 食べて心を刺激させる
音を聞いて心を刺激させるということで生きているんですね
それで心の刺激ということを研究した方がいいんです
心っていうのは 怒り 憎しみ
妄想 そんなもので刺激しているんですよ
例えば小説を読んだり
映画を見たりとかで 怒り
憎しみ もう戦い もうあらゆる人間の汚れた感情をね
頭の中で作るんですよ
作って心の栄養にしているんです
これとんでもないことだと
心っていうのはものすごい穴だらけの器だと
いくら入れても足らないんですよ
体では人が一生どれぐらい金儲かるかということは数字で決まってるでしょ
でも心に聞いてみてください
あんたはどれぐらい金儲ければ満足するかというと
数字がないんですよ 舌で物理学的に見ればどれぐらい味味わえるかと
お腹の量から見ればどれぐらい量食べれば終わりかということははっきり数字あるんですよ
あるにも関わらず 心に聞いてみてください
どれぐらい美味しいものを食べればあんたは満足するか
わからないんですよ それぐらい心っていうのはすごい穴持ってますよ
ですから この これ 心の恐ろしさ
危険性を理解してほしい
それから心の中で この憎しみ
欲 嫉妬 怒り そんなものを回転させて
妄想 雑念 くだらん思考
そんなものを回転させて
この心に刺激を与えるんじゃないんですよ
ひどくなるんです ですから
優しさ 慈しみ 欲のない思考
もっと知識的な思考 すべては無常であると変化していくんだとかね
一番頭が良くなるのは仏教を勉強すること
それほど頭が良くなる学問はないんです
ものすごく ものすごいたくさん物事はあるんですよ
ですから この仏教的に
生きていると すごい生き方は単純ですよ
ものすごい余裕が出てくる
いくらでも時間が出てくる
お金もいくらも余裕が出てくる
アホらしい生き方やめてるんだから
服のために生きてることをやめていて
生きてるんだから 服買ってるんだからね
そうするとお金の余裕が出てくる
時間の余裕が出てくる
妄想しないと思考の余裕が出てくる
それを思う存分 このものすごい超越したこの智慧を得るために使ってくださいと
仏教を勉強することによってもお金はかかるでしょうね
自分がどこかに座って勉強しなくちゃいけないし
ご飯食べなくちゃいけないし
いろいろなことはありますからね
お金の余裕があるんで
その場合は そういうふうに
このお釈迦様が智慧も知識もきれいにするようにと
ですから 慈しみの思考
それから論理って何なのか
真理って何なのかと 因果法則って何なのかと
無常って何なのかと 人間って生命って何なのかとかね
そういうことを勉強すると心の栄養にはなるし
頭すごく良くなってしまうし
結果として完全に解脱まで得られるんですね
それ人生は成功したことになるんですね
それは心の栄養ということで
とにかく とりあえず今でもこの憎しみ
嫉妬なんか考えて その刺激で生きることだけでもやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと
その代わりに優しさ 人の気持ちも理解しようとする努力
そういうところを育ててみればいいんじゃないかなとは思います
今日もたくさん教典は持ってきましたけど
一つも紹介することができなかった
こちらもいろいろ提案がありまして
この話してほしいという
触ってない問題としては
この人間というのは悲観的に考えちゃう場合があるんだと
物事を悲観的に考えて極端に行って禁欲主義者になってしまうと
1つの人間の極端な走り方に
また楽観的な考え方している人もいるんだと言って
結局走り回って快楽主義に走っちゃうんだと
だから この 困ったことが続くと
すぐ悲観的になる 悲観的になって困ったことすると
どんどん注意深くなるようになっちゃうんですね
警戒するようになる で
警戒して心配して そのパターンに考え方になってしまって
もう禁欲主義になる あれもやらない
これもやらない もう危険だ
危険だ 騙されるかもしれませんとかね
困ったことになっちゃうと
例えば一回結婚失敗したら
もうこれでものすごい警戒して
もう絶対嫌だとかね
死んでもやらんとかね
結婚なんかという なんか変な禁欲主義に極端的になるとかよくあるんですね
それは警戒 余計な警戒とかね
そういうところから出てくる
逆の場合でも同じで 何かうまくいっちゃうと
自分が何でもよくできるぞとか
もう快楽主義になって
ものすごいもう変なもう恐ろしい生き方をしてしまっちゃうという
その問題についても喋ってほしいという要件ですけど
一応これはもう答えはこの充実感ということなんですね
日々充実感あればそういう問題は起きません
充実感がないんだから悲観的になる
で 楽観的になるのももう愚か者だから
この世の中で何一つもうまくいくということはないんですよ
うまくいく ついているというのはありえないことなんですよ
すべてチャレンジなんですよ
これはもう原子レベルでもチャレンジなんですよ
お互いに奪い合って成り立ってますよ
だからもう何か得ようということは
その分頑張らなくちゃいかんことで
楽観主義っていうのは成り立たないんですよ
ですから それは無知ということなんですね
だから無知な人は楽観主義で
これは何かグループにあったことはありますよ
商売をやっている会社の人々で
もううまくやっている人で
えらい傲慢なんですね
態度が わしらなんかはこんな宗教とかね
そんなのなんか全然気にしないとかね
そんなもの本当は全然要りませんとかね
でもうこういう 宗教をやっている人々の悪口言ったりしてね
もう何言うかとね それは確かに日本の社会ではね
商売失敗するって人々はもう御利益を求めて
宗教というもうとんでもない
どうでもいいところに走り回りますけど
どうせ判断ミスだから
宗教に走っても判断ミスは判断ミスなんですよ
宗教で商売繁盛してくれるわけじゃないんです
そこで商売うまくいってる人々っていうのは
これ自分が思考パターンで淡々と頑張ってるからでしょうに
正しい判断をして 正しい商売に手を出して
それで成功しているでしょうに
それがわかってなくて
わしがやれば何でもうまくいくんだぞと
これがもう危険であって
そんなことないんですよ
頑張ってるんだからうまくいってるんですよ
変な思考がないんだからうまくいってるだけで
それに気づかない限りは危険なんですね
やがて失敗する  何会社でしたっけ？もう陽気印になっちゃいます
かダイエーかどちらかわからないんですけど
ですから うまくいくんだぞ
そんなことないでしょう
このダイエーでしたっけ？あの今
かなりものすごい大きいデパートのチェーンがね
かなり潰れていってね
まだまだ生きてはいますけどね
あれも同じことですよ
楽観主義 え？あ そごう
です そごうですね ダイエーに来るかもしれません
訂正します [笑い] やっぱりあまりにも楽観主義で大きくなりすぎでしょ
そこで判断ミスでしょ
日本のバブル状況でも同じこと
判断ミスでしょ それは楽観主義で危険なことになったということなんです
やっぱり物事っていうのはそううまくいくわけじゃないんですよ
きちんと明晰に理解して行動するべきなんですよ
それを忘れちゃうと どこかで必ず落とし穴がある
そういうことだから このちゃんと理性を保って
秒単位で満足して充実感で生きている
各1秒で精一杯最高な生き方をする
この1秒でできる最高な生き方をすると
その人は死ぬまで最高な生き方をします
それで余裕が出ていけたら
智慧としても最高な生き方に至ることはできるんですよ
ということで 話を終了させていただきます
ありがとうございます